hey guys and welcome back to the layah heilpern
show powered by icon plus as usual so a quick
message from them if you are tired of high
gas fess on uniswap then you can now swap
your ethereum based tokens on icon through orbit
chain so all you have to do if you want to do that
is visit bridge.orbitchain.io and then try it out
i also want to say thank you to block by they are
one of my sponsors um i use them to earn up to 8.6
interest on my usdc so that's insane 8.6 interest
um right now you have negative interest rates
across europe um i think it's pretty terrible
in the states as well in england you've got 0.01
so if you can get 8.6 interest and that's amazing
um so i'm going to leave the link everywhere for
you you can get 250 dollars when you sign up so
that's really cool and also before we start the
show because this one is a little bit different
so it's going to be pretty cool um i want to say
another huge shout out to coinflip they sponsor
the show um and they're doing some incredible work
across the states to push bitcoin mass adoption
they now have 1 400 bitcoin atms um giving access
to every day pic everyday people which i think is
really cool so i have a 10 discount code if you
guys want it and i'll leave that in the comments
so joining me today is a pretty interesting
guest somebody that i met through twitter but
i have actually been able to meet in real life
as well he is kind of known as convict turned
conqueror pretty interesting oh i think he's he's
actually just gone i'm not sure why he's gone
let's just find out why i can't get him hang on
oh there we go he's back he's back is bobby back
oh wow bobby there you go i don't know what
happened i hit the retweet and it just went
poof and i was gone so i missed it yeah no you're
here on time you're here perfectly on time how
are you doing i'm doing well i'm doing a lot and
yourself yeah i'm good i'm good so you are really
interesting um you call yourself convict turned
us i want to get into all of that but before we do
i've got we've got to talk about bitcoin
because right now it's almost hitting 40k
and i know you're a little bit into crypto so just
give me your thoughts i mean a little bit yeah i i
totally uh am behind the movement i recommend it
to people um i i really started studying it back
in march like right when covet hit and started
reading what people were were putting out there
about it and not not no offense to people that are
on social media but not necessarily social media
talking heads more like you know the financial
experts and and whatnot and um and saw that it was
it was going to go places so i got into it uh told
others they should get into it which just it's
made me feel like this financial wizard because
i've had more than a couple people tell me like
man you really called it on on the bitcoin bro
like that like it's crazy you know and it it has
been it's great awesome yeah it's it's absolutely
insane especially you know if you started in
march 2020 then wow you've got to see the rise of
like over 20 grand in one year like that's insane
um but i want to kind of go back a little bit and
understand a little bit about you because we met
through twitter but we had the chance to meet in
romania and you know you call yourself convict
time congress so what does that mean why are you
across what happened to us well okay so so back
in 2000 uh i was leading kind of this hedonistic
lifestyle to where i was doing illegal activity
um i was just not really caring about anyone
or anything else about myself and i got into
an altercation and wound up going to prison
in california i was there for originally for
five years but then got into some more problems
while i was in and had to end up doing a decade
total and um about halfway through i just i came
to this realization you know i'm reading these
different books and self-help books and whatnot
and i came to this realization like wow man
everything's on me i got to take responsibility
for my life you know this isn't other people's
problems this is my problems i got to fix it
so it was just this turning point for me and um
i i essentially stopped running around with
the people that were in there and and just
went off on my own uh did some studying got into
some vocations uh lined up a job for when i got
out and uh really kind of just hit the ground
running and everything that i've put my mind to
since then once i once i came to that realization
that okay you got to take responsibility for
everything and you have to commit you know you
have to follow through do it it's like there
hasn't been anything that's that i haven't been
able to do so that's what i talk to people about
they they find it inspiring for me it's just you
know the life i've lived but you know i mean it
you could do what you put your mind to and that's
that's the hurdle that a lot of people have that
it's true that you there's just so many examples
that you can't deny it so what happened you know
you said you sort of got mixed up with the wrong
people and you sort of say that you know you had
that turning point so can you take us through
the journey how did it start and what was that
sort of turning point inside i know you said you
did longer than you expected right yeah so uh
i can't i i come from people that uh and and them
uh have been associated with people my whole life
that the law enforcement would would consider
like a criminal type element okay um like like
an organized criminal type element so uh from from
a young age i i saw the kind of um i don't want to
say glamour because it's not necessarily glamorous
but i saw the kind of cool lifestyle uh that there
was and um you know the people that were around
and all that and so uh it made me want to get into
it i got into it while i was still in high school
you know started doing little different different
jobs you know and um and was getting stacks of
money you know and so uh it was something that
was appealing but at the same time i always knew
it was wrong and so then i started getting into
things to cope with that you know um i i started
uh not drinking like like um like gnarly but you
know i started drinking alcohol i started smoking
pot you know i was doing all these different
things to kind of just numb that that away um and
then when i did when i did end up going to prison
you know i went in thinking like okay i gotta do
what i have to do you know like i'm not you know
this is a it's a hardcore place so you have to
handle your business and if something comes up
or you got to defend yourself or you got to fight
or whatever it is you just do what you got to do
and that's what i did and i i did that for
for five years and what ended up happening um
was about four years in um i was hanging out with
some guys that uh we were in our little work area
our workshop and these guys were having um free
staff uh which are um prison employees that aren't
the corrections officers you know right uh
they were having these free staff bring them
in pot and different drugs and whatever and
so we were in the shop and the cops came in
and uh they they found a baggie with with like
the residue of some pot in it and they found it
near me okay so uh and they were like oh this
is yours and i'm like no it's not you know and
they mirandize me which um for for american speak
that's just when they go uh you have the right to
remain silent anything you oh your miranda rights
right yeah yeah right yeah so so so they they they
ran my miranda rights down to me and as soon as
they did that i was like okay i want a lawyer
you know like i'm not i don't have anything to say
you know and that pot was uh point zero zero zero
one grams okay it was an unusable amount it was
it was literally like the residue inside of a bag
like if you would empty the bag you know like held
it upside down and dumped it all out what would
still be left in there that little just crap yeah
crumbs yeah uh right so uh so they they charged me
uh took me to court and and i i was like well i
got this beat you know that's why i so i i took
it to trial i'm like i got this beat you
know it's not on me it's you know whatever
and one of the cops got up on the stand and he
said oh yeah he admitted it was his and um you
know he did that oh yeah like you know i mean
they do that stuff all the time but like i mean
yeah so um so i ended up getting uh six years
added on to my sentence and uh yeah it was
crazy because um i went in for you know what's
essentially a violent crime you know it was it was
an assault with a great bodily injury uh and i got
more time for the residue in that bag than i did
for like hurting someone so it was a crazy thing
you know but but even then right like later later
on you know about a year later i'm kind of reading
these books and going through stuff myself and
just getting sick with the whole situation even
with that i have to take responsibility for that
you know like like i was messing around with
those dudes in the shop okay i'd smoke some of
that weed with them you know what i mean like i
was i was partying with them and everything like
that like if i would if i would have been totally
away from them you know not having anything to do
with people like that none of that would have so i
still have to take responsibility for that i know
people hear that you know they hear the amount
and then they go six years for five you know
they get like call you know but it's like yo man
i put myself there and that's part of what i mean
when i say taking responsibility is you really
have to direct your life and it sounds so easy
when you say it right but that's some of the
hardest thing that the majority of the population
has uh you know to do it's like something that
it's just a real stumbling block for people
yeah it is and i think that's one of um the
biggest issues that we're seeing in society now
particularly when we talk about when people sort
of talk about the decline of the west um because
you know people are just unable to do that i
mean even if we look at the education system
um it's sort of from a young age we're not taught
to take responsibility particularly when we have
things like participation trophies then it's
kind of like you know you you don't even take
responsibility for the losing because you're
still sort of rewarded and a kind of perverse
way if that makes sense yeah yeah totally you
know um it's just it's this really um there's this
this softness that has been created
um in society by just trying to remove
the element of violence and death and and you know
any anything bad right so we just pretend that it
doesn't exist and what happens is it makes people
soft you know that's why you see people that um
and not necessarily everyone but you see
many uh that have like either been in war
or been in prison for that matter or been through
through some you know maybe maybe their their uh
you know police officers or
whatever just people that have
seen the underbelly you know what i
mean and um those people tend to just
kind of be able to take you know and move forward
with life right you know they just they handle
what needs to be done you know i mean i can even
tell you in the in the uk as an example we have
a lot of um we have a lot of immigrants that come
from ex-soviet countries and they uh and i've met
a lot of them they're all fantastic and they have
a very different mindset when it comes to covid
in that they don't care they just don't care
because because they've been through enough
you know like they've been through enough they
you know their parents grew up in absolute poverty
under communism and so on and so when it comes
to covid that's the least of their worries you
know it's just a different mentality but you
mentioned this shady officer or whatever so
what's it actually like inside so how tribal is it
like i'm gonna be honest you know like is it like
the movies is it you know super tribal whether
it be like segregated by race religion um you
know men just just too much testosterone in one
place like what's it like okay so so let me let
me throw this disclaimer out there right now okay
i was in california state prison um that's that's
known as being a pretty gnarly place okay there
are 50 states in in the united states so what i
speak about in california might be different for
kansas or for something else i don't know you know
so i'm just gonna speak to my situation uh okay
so so i didn't really know what racism was until
i went to prison because it is everything is race
like everything and it's it's so stringent that
there are these weird barriers that you just can't
cross right um like for example let's say let's
say a black guy is smoking a cigarette right and
he offers you a hit or whatever you can't take a
hit off of that cigarette why not not a sick well
the black it's the black guy's cigarette his mouth
offering it to you same with the drink like let's
say they've got a drink of water or they've got a
drink you can't drink off of that same that same
cup even if he's offering it to you yeah right
i mean it is that racial right who would have
the problem as a white person would you have the
problem or would the the black people have
a problem who would have an issue from you
that's kind of funny because because um because
really it would be a white issue because i know
okay i knew that like some of these black og's
you know when we say og we just mean you know some
older guy that's been in the game for a minute
handles his stuff right they would do that type
of stuff on purpose to white guys like when they
talk to us i'd be like they'd be like hey man you
want a drink you know hey you want they try and
trip them up because they know they knew that that
there was these rules that were followed right but
to get back about how it was it was super duper
racial and you know we're feeling too uh being
a white guy from orange county which is a uh
like a republican beach county that's you know
right next door to la and in southern california
um i never really experienced racism coming
towards me you know i'd seen it going
like away from me like you know towards other
people but yeah like once i've been in there
and and it is very heavily i mean it's you
know there's there's white people there too
but i mean black and mexican you know i mean
there's all different types of ethnicities right
and feeling it like coming towards me
you know and it was weird because um
because it was so racial like that and so
segregated you really felt kind of like the hate
uh a lot of times coming off of people you know
people trying to make light of it while you're
in there you know you could bs play cards joke
do whatever go work out but the reality of it is
it's a prison is a place that's kind of built
on despair you know it's just you're here you
got to be here you can't go anywhere try and
leave will kill you uh and i mean that's just
it is what it is you know we're gonna have
riots and we're gonna do this and that and
yeah it's just it's not a fun place
i don't recommend anybody going there
yeah i mean it's really interesting you know when
you of course you know you mentioned about prison
but i think that's a huge difference between the
us and the uk everything is so racial everything
is based on those lines i just think it's
because of the history of the country um
we don't have that it's so incredible and i talked
to a lot of americans about it and we don't have
that divide between the two races nobody really
cares we're sort of british before anything else
like it's insane that i think that you guys say
african-american like if you said if you said like
african british people would just be like excuse
me like it's almost offensive it's crazy yeah it
is you know um it's kind of like i remember when
i was growing up uh my my grandfather wouldn't say
italian-american right because uh he he was
an american italian he was an american with
italian heritage right exactly he he had pride in
that uh yeah so yeah i i get that and you'd think
california being as progressive as it is that
it wouldn't be that way but it is california
state prisons are are just gnarly nasty places
and there's bad stuff that happens all the time
and it's super duper racial um you know the weird
thing is is they have all these race rules right
but all those go out the window when right
comes into play so oh okay right so you can't
be friends you can't do whatever this and that
but but wait the the the mexicans have dope you
know or they've got this or that okay we can talk
and go away so you know that's where a lot of the
the riots would start from would be that
somebody got something from another race
they remade on paying you know they didn't pay
their bill uh and then um it built up and the two
end up going at it you know
so essentially it's over debt
so then how how does somebody reform right
because you know you you have in your twitter bio
convict and conqueror how do you get from convicts
or conqueror how can how can you reform though
because people either come out of two ways right
they either come out how you've come out or they
sort of do it all again or they've been in so long
like the famous film shawshank redemption and they
become institutionalized and they don't want to
leave after all you know so how do you get to that
how do you win in the end you know well you have
to put in the work you have to have a want and
desire you can't especially people that are going
down that road to where they found themselves in
prison because believe it or not prison is a rock
bottom for some people you think that would be
their rock bottom it's not god i'm locked up but
for some people that ain't it like they still
they still have a journey they gotta make so uh
when you see people come going down that road
you can't pick them up and take them off and they
either can steer away and kind of listen to what
you have to say to them or or not so you have to
have that desire to want to change your life and
then from there there's certain there's certain
avenues that you can take advantage of as long
as you recognize them and are willing to jump
on them and what what i mean by that is this
um okay everybody in prison is assigned a job
detail and that's what you have to do you know
you get up you go to the job and that's how you
get some time taken off your sentences that you go
to work right yeah they also have the education
and vocations right so the place that i was at
had a vocational welding and machine shop and yeah
and i know that the the job that i i had lined up
for me when i got out and that i could do that
was part of what they did was welding so i was
like okay here's where i can build some skills
right here and have something for when i get out
so you have to be able to to adapt and recognize
in your situation what it is that you need to do
um i have a story there's a website for those
uh it's listed right there bobbydyno.com there
there's um some some blog articles i have there
i'm gonna ask you about this yeah where i recount
some of the you know my experiences and one of
those is where i i had to walk away from the
the race group you know and that's uh
that's a tricky situation because it's not
like if you don't believe in if if you don't
believe in yourself and have the conviction to
do it or like if you come up like kind of half ass
or whatever uh you can find yourself in trouble
you know it's like you're either hot or cold
but don't be lukewarm you know don't be right
in the fence and uh it's i don't know that
everybody could do it the way that i did it
but i know that uh if people really have the
desire they can do it somehow does that make sense
like yeah it does it does i think like you have
to really want it it's like anything difficult
in life like you have to have that desire um
but i guess not everybody has enough desire to
sort of go out and actually put in the work and
make that change but speaking of your blog um i
was going through it the other day and there are
some pretty interesting stories on there um there
was one story which i want to ask you about if
you could tell us in the most pc way possible
about a big gay steve gay yeah tell us about that
one okay so so another disclaimer all the names
have been changed but but uh yeah so there's this
guy um there was this guy big gay steve and he was
like football player big like football
like like and i mean american football
uh like linebacker big um i mean this guy i'm 6'4
and 240 pounds and i looked small next to this
oh wow yeah like he had he had
this is crazy okay he had 20 inch
forearms like his his forearms which one most
dudes don't have 20 inch biceps you know like
a 20 inch bicep you know you're looking or you're
looking all right you know for the arms and he was
bigger he's much bigger than you because you're
like gigantic for those that don't know like bobby
is huge so he was he was like six six or something
like that like he was taller than me yeah and he
was just very big i mean i think i want to say he
weighed like 340 or 350 pounds like that's i weigh
240. so i mean yeah this dude was just he was
big um like nfl big you know and um so he was one
of the guys that was considered an enforcer for
obvious reasons so like let's say you're a new guy
they call them fish your fish rolling up to the
yard right uh your white guy they want to see your
paperwork they want to see your what you're in for
we used to call them a 128 because that was the
what the form the number of the form was you know
so we'd say let me see your 128 right so you check
their paperwork um he was one of those guys that
did that you know uh he was uh he was he was a
beast and he was one of those guys too that uh he
and he enjoyed the role right so it it was like i
at first when i first met him he didn't come
off as a bully but he enjoyed being the guy
that people were afraid of and as i knew steve uh
he just got kind of got progressively worse and
things with him got weird uh people can read this
story i don't want to give it all away you know
but essentially uh he he started bullying people
for different things uh first it was their their
property uh later it was you know uh allegedly for
other stuff yeah and and uh he was someone that
we didn't want somebody like that around
okay um are you familiar with jeffrey dahmer
no okay so jeffrey dahmer was this guy in america
that was like he was a serial killer but he was
he was a sicko um he he did it to men uh i could
obviously dismember them would keep body ate some
some of them body parts when they caught them were
in the freezer i mean just know so when he went to
prison he went to the pc section the protective
custody section right because he was famous
you know they got a and even there two attempts
were made on his life the second one being
being successful they killed him on the second
try and it was within like a year or something
and people go wow you know and that's you know
i wonder why they they tried so hard to kill him
and the thing is you don't want some creep you
know around you you don't want somebody that you
don't know what they're gonna do when you close
your eyes you know they're gonna try and saw your
head off or do whichever right and nobody felt
comfortable with that dude around and he had to go
okay that's what ended up happening with steve uh
oh wow okay yeah he's he started kind of getting
creepy you know um with just the things he was
doing and it just came to the decision of of
the group that hey this this guy's he needs to go
he can't be what happens though what happens when
that happens like is there an investigation
or does it just no okay so okay what do you
mean like like what happens as far as like if
somebody gets hurt or killed or what happened
it's a homicide yeah it's murder most of
the time you know but it's always a homicide
uh yeah so it's like a crime scene investigation
they'll they'll lock the building down you know
everybody's got to go to their cells
or dorms depending on where you live
they come in they do the pictures they do
the outlet i mean it's it's like what you'd
see on tv um and they they usually end
up finding the person that's responsible
uh but yeah uh it's but it's not always a murder
um sometimes it's just you know you beat him up or
you do something real you hurt them real bad
and then they go you know so it just depends
so you're now the author of thinking tough um
which essentially is what it says on on the
book right it's essentially thinking tough it's
you know it's what it says which thing's great
um i want to talk about what's
going on in today's society because
it's sort of become a bit of a personality trait
to sort of have depression and have anxiety
and um to be a victim you know everybody sort
of celebrates victim mentality these days so
you know why are people doing this what do
you think and how can we sort of and why is
that bad for society especially in terms of
you know men taking on that kind of mentality
well i i mean people people tend to seek
comfort and people tend to shirk responsibility
so when you have that victim mentality right you
don't have to take responsibility for anything
because it's something happening to you
you know it's not anything that you're doing
right because then you'd have to be responsible
or anything you're not doing for that matter
right it's something happening to you so you
you get to to not have to accept that you're the
one that that puts yourself there uh so comfort um
trying to shy away from responsibility uh
and then really it's a direction thing are
i i was lucky i was raised by somebody that
was raised by people that were born in the 20s
okay so i kind of got like this different
um feel uh this different education
uh and i and i noticed it from even my
high school years the way that my peers
would act you know and were different and how
they thought and whatnot uh but a lot of that is
because the the generation you know the
boomers or or whatever you want to call them uh
you they raise their kids absence of this kind of
toughness you know oh we're not going to hit them
we're not going to yell at them we're not going to
do anything to them we're going to just you know
baby them and do whatever it it continued and
it's created what's just essentially soft men
i mean that's why i say it's good the the way
that you solve something like that is that you
you have to have a mission or or some type of
challenge or some type of something put in in
front of you repeatedly um there was this uh god i
think it was uh starship troopers and that's funny
that i didn't remember that for a second because
i have a family member that's in that movie but uh
they they um that was a book originally and
they had like to where you did mandatory
military service it was like if you
wanted to be a citizen you had to give
a couple years i think there's other countries
that actually do that i don't know if it's israel
is it yes yeah you've got mandatory yeah i i think
that's a good thing i think that's a good thing
you know i i can understand yeah yeah it teaches
you this responsibility and it teaches you um
it shows you the underbelly depending on on the
situation and really makes you decide for yourself
hey am i gonna live or am i going to die you know
because essentially that's everything's choices
but the big choices are that you know it's like
putting a roof over your head or am i going to
pay rent or am i going to go to this party you
know it's like essentially they boil down to
that am i going to live or die and so so yeah i
think that there's just too many options and too
many different avenues that people can take that
just lead to comfort and shy away from i mean like
look at what was that uh was it cosmo or something
that put that picture up yes like come on man like
do you see what i mean it's just like like
so now we're just gonna just start denying
the existence yeah yeah so for those that don't
know yeah i'll just say for those that don't know
so i think on the front cover of cosmopolitan
um magazine they had some clearly overweight
and obese women posing and it had written
this as healthy even though we all know in
reality there's nothing healthy about obesity
um so we're sort of like denying reality to
not offend people um and that is just the most
ridiculous um surreal world to live in which
i think we're just going to go down a
terrible kind of route if we continue
going down that that that kind of path um
but yeah it it's happening everywhere um
i don't know what it is and i don't know whether
i don't know whether we're going to go so far that
we're sort of like do a correction at some
point um you know a bit i guess a bit like
financial markets if you're gonna look at it like
that but we're absolutely denying reality in so
many different places and i think you're totally
right when you talk about um you know parents and
how they've sort of had parents have become softer
and you even see this in different cultures anyway
you see in so many different cultures african
parents compared to western parents um very
different and it's really interesting to see but
i have an interesting question i want to quickly
chat to you about as well because when we met you
told me that you had spent the most of your life
in the states so you'd never actually left the
states before up until you were until i don't
know you are much older and so there's that but
there's also you were told that you were living in
not just the best country in the world but in
california which is the best state in the world
in the best in the best city on the best road
in the best like what like that is okay so so
here's what's up and i know that people from
from uh the states are gonna probably not like
this this next comment coming out but but
if they're honest that if they're honest
okay so americans are told that this is the best
country on the planet and and in a lot of ways
from from when i've when i've the travels i've
seen and stuff there are a lot of ways to where
it is superior okay i will say that okay but
being from california we're told that we live in
the best state in the best country on the planet
and very funny if you're from southern california
right where the weather is nice and where you
know it's like you can't deny it you're just like
yeah i do i live in california there's the pacific
coast here's my beach you know i'm i'm here here's
my here's my nice weather all year round so yeah
that is definitely something that's just kind of
at least for me it was when i was a
kid it was just kind of drilled you
know into us it's just like man we're in
the best spot and you go different places
and you see ways that maybe you're not the
best but you also see you also see ways that um
to where you are uh one one one of the ways for
example like when we're talking about romania um
the people over there have much more of
a straightforward attitude and more of a
mind their own business attitude as well okay
that's fantastic yeah which is which is cool
you know so when you're talking to someone
they're just being you know okay what it is
right right up front with you there's there's
no bs okay and and they mind their business
you know you're playing your music a little
too loud nobody's gonna call the cops you
know nobody's gonna do they don't like that they
don't like any of that okay so that's cool however
america's cool and and the thing where america
in my opinion from what i've seen thus far
has pretty much everybody be that is
america's place to where you can get
anything with as much as you want anytime you
want it like it's just the place to where it's
just like the land of plenty right some place
you need you need something go right now there's
there's 400 stores that sell it you know i mean
like it's just it's just that place to where
you can get and there's we won't run out you know
like that that's another thing it's like that that
weird feeling that um it's just there and when
you go to other countries and you see that like
okay they've only got two stores or okay they
they only sell this or oh wow you can't get this
and then you're just you kind of realize like
wow okay we've just got everything over here
yeah it's insane i think america is just a whole
universe of its own i mean forget the state being
their own thing anyway the the the individual
stakes just america as a whole like you guys have
a have such an american mentality in a way in in a
way which is so different to brits and i think the
the thing which really gets me is that people
often think like the uk and the usa are sort of
like one of the same we speak the same language
we have very similar culture and you know we get
on as if we're the same but we're so different
so you've not been to the uk but i spent i spent
about three months living in the u.s when i was 18
or 19 or whatever and i felt so foreign i felt so
foreign like forget that the money's different it
was just like the energy and the mentality and i
was working on a kid's summer camp and the kids
all broke out at one point literally chanting
u-s-a-u-s-a i couldn't believe my eyes couldn't
believe it i was like that's insane as if kids in
the uk would stop being like england england
no unless you're a football match like yeah
yeah there definitely is an american lens um i
had to catch myself you know i had to catch myself
when i was over and because i was over in romania
for like 10 months or something like that like
10 almost 11 months and are you done there by the
way are you going back no no i'm i'm i'm here i'm
here okay um but uh it was it was definitely one
of those things to where there is when when you're
an american you go other place there is this
kind of lens that you view things with and i'd
have to catch myself sometimes during interactions
because like funny like we as americans you know
we have the freedom of speech we have the freedom
of this we have the freedom of that we've got guns
we've got whatever we just so like if for me i'm
going to speak my mind you say something i'll say
something back you know like i'll just yeah you
know or whatever like if you start getting stupid
i'm gonna call you on it like that's just and in
other cultures that's not necessarily how it works
there there's a little bit of a game to it
you know and you don't so i would have to
catch myself sometimes from being the arrogant
american you know or like the [ __ ] american you
know because uh i was a guest in another country
and and i didn't want to come across as you know
what not but there definitely is is an american
lens to when you go different places for sure
i've got to tell you um americans are great
i love you guys so no one's taking personally
a banter but like in the uk like when you hear
like americans you're just like oh americans
you're just like like troubles yeah it's just
like oh god they're gonna be really loud they're
gonna be really obnoxious like because brits we're
just really we're just like really tamed and we're
really you know we've got our stiff upper lip
and like we're just and like it's funny because
these stereotypes don't come from nowhere you
know um so i just think it's found i think it's
fascinating that you'd sort of said you know you
thought you'd grown up in the best country but not
just the best country the best state it blew my
mind but just with your whole story in mind then
what would be kind of like the main or like
the biggest lesson that you've learned the most
uh i think that the biggest the biggest lesson
okay and this is for anybody that's that's really
struggling out there that's watching or may
hear this or whatnot first and foremost you
have to take responsibility for your station
meaning that wherever you're at in life
whatever it is you're doing for a job wherever you
become you know whatever that's you that's on you
you chose that at some point okay so once you
realize that you are the one that's putting
yourself in situations it's a negative situation
realize that you can put yourself in a positive
situation because you're calling the shots for
you so take take responsibility for your life
and come up with the plan of action to get
somewhere and not like a wish list not like you
know uh i want to be an astronaut you know or i
want to be whichever that's that's a that's a wish
you know come up with with something everything
anything that you want to be has been laid out
before you i got other people have done it yeah
like journalism for example you want to be a be
in journalism well there's uh you know education
you take for journey you get three in this you
get that you get you call a station here you do
whatever the the steps are to apply and get in
it's it's been laid out so it's once you commit
and and come to a plan of action then you just
have to put in the work you put in the work
and your time will come like that yeah i think
that's what it does yeah i think it's such an
important thing to sort of make clear because
i was thinking about this yesterday that a lot of
the time i'm talking about personal responsibility
um people don't like it i think aoc sort of said
called the republicans the responsibility party
as if it's a bad thing um which is hilarious but
but it's it's the most incredible thing because
imagine being so out of control like once you
understand that you know you can have that kind of
responsibility that's amazing imagine not having
any control of your life it just sounds awful
yeah you know yeah for sure for sure yeah it's
something it's like it's like being on the
the ocean right in a ship without a rudder like
you just get blown to where i mean if you're not
taking responsibility everything is happening
to you you aren't happening it's it's it's being
put on you and who'd want to live like that why
would you want to live your life like that yeah
you know and i think i and i think like
it shouldn't be a sort of um political
statement it shouldn't be a you know if you take
personal responsibility now suddenly i know that
you're more on this end of the political spectrum
not like it should just be um something fantastic
and to empower people and sort of say you know
like don't worry because actually you can change
that you don't have to wait for the bureaucratic
government to sign your papers and and say that
you're approved and you know we we agree you're
worthy of it no you can just go and do um and
i think i found the most amazing things so
bobby where can people find you where can
people reach you where can they find you so so
i'm on twitter at real bobby dino i'm also on uh
instagram under the same thing uh you can
read the articles at bobbydino.com uh and
you know different places on social media
and shows like these but but bobbydyno.com
and twitter and this other social media stuff is
is where to look perfect bobby thank you so much
such a pleasure to have you on um and guys
don't forget to tune in next thursday 12 p.m est
so thank you so much bobby hey thank you for
having me i appreciate it alright bye guys